I watched a rain man again I thought it
held up pretty well but again you
couldn't make it because like he says
the r word a million times yeah that
kind of stuff we're like in kindergarten
now where we have to say peepee and poo
poo and r word well Animal House I think
Animal House still holds up but you can
you could not do that movie if you
really examine who you are you probably
are not offended at all we all laughed
at this stuff and it wasn't terribly we
know what something's terribly offensive
but when you hear it now in 2023 you
hunch up because you know not because of
it itself but because you know the
reaction will cause yes we can have the
most incredible Alliance forming right
now of those ex-libs and the
Libertarians and the conservatives and
the religious people and we can put
together something under the banner of
freedom